hello and welcome to this session on
data science
my name is mohan and today we are going
to take a look at
what this buzz is all about so what is
the agenda for today
we will talk about what is the need for
data science and then what exactly is
data science some definitions
then we'll talk about the prerequisites
for learning data science
and then what does a data scientist do
what are the activities performed by a
data scientist as a part of his
daily life and then we will talk about
the data science
life cycle with a quick example and
briefly touch upon the demand
or ever increasing demand for data
scientists
all right so let's get started now
you must have already heard about
autonomous cars
so i'm sure you must be excited to have
a car driving by itself which will take
you from home to office or office to
home right and that's where
one of the examples where data science
is used now the car needs to take
a lot of decisions in this whole process
whether to speed up whether to apply the
brake
take a left turn right turn or slow down
so all these decisions are basically a
part of data science
and there is a study that says that
self-driving cars
will minimize accidents
and in fact it will root out more than 2
million deaths
caused by car accidents annually
self-driving cars
right now there's a lot of research and
there is a lot of testing going on
and not a lot of cars are yet
in production in terms of usage
but it's going to happen every
automotive
company worth its name is investing in
self-driving cars
so in about 10 to 15 years some of the
studies say that
most of the cars will be autonomous or
self-driving cars
where else there are issues for example
if we take airlines this is another area
where data science contributes in a
major way flights get delayed due to
weather conditions because the weather
is not predicted
in time and the demand of passengers
is not probably seen ahead of time for
all these unique data science then this
could be
improper route planning and
some customers might miss some flights
that again
needs data science and similarly it
could be
incorrect decisions in selecting the
right equipment so
which plane should fly in which route
that's the equipment
that's being mentioned here if that is
not planned properly
then you might end up in a situation
where the plane is not available whereas
you have planned
for a flight in a particular route so
these are
some of the challenges in one of the
representative industries we are talking
about which is
airlines so if we use data science
properly all of these or most of these
problems can be
avoided and that will help in reducing
the pain
both for the airlines and also for the
passengers
a few more examples what else can we do
here are some of the other things that
we can do
and we will stick to the airline
industry we can do better route planning
so that there are less cancellations and
less frustrated people
we can predict use predictive analytics
and predict any delays that are there so
that
some flights can be rescheduled ahead of
time
and there are no last minute changes
data science can also be used to
make promotional offers and the last but
not least
is what kind of planes should be used or
the different classes of planes that
should be used
in different routes for better
performance so these are some
examples of how data science can be used
in
airlines and another example or in the
industry where data science can be used
and benefited would be
in logistics so companies like fedex
they use data science models to increase
their
efficiency drastically to optimize the
routes
and cut costs and so on so before
their delivery truck actually sets out
they determine
which is the best possible route to ship
their items to the customers and based
on various inputs
they also predict or come up with the
best suited time to deliver
and last but not least they determine
what is the best
mode of transport for this delivery as
well so what is data science
used for these are some of the main
areas where
data science is used for better decision
making there are
always tricky decisions to be made so
which is the right decision which way to
go so that is one area
then for predicting for performing
predictive analysis
like for example can we predict delays
like in the case of
airlines can we predict the demand for
certain products let's say in e-commerce
that is the second area the third area
is pattern
discovery or pattern recognition is
there a pattern
in which people are buying items for
example it could be
seasonality if you take the data sales
data for
multiple years there may be a pattern in
the way
people are buying that's a buying
pattern
certain months probably the sales will
increase certain months if sales will
come down
certain quarters traditionally the sales
will be higher certain quarters
so that is a pattern and this pattern
discovery is another area where data
science is
applied so what is data science
now let's take an example a real life
example on a day-to-day basis
we use or we try to make some decisions
let's say we want to buy some
furniture online for our new office so
how do you go about doing this you need
to take a bunch of
decisions to actually do the purchase so
we start with which website which portal
or which website
you should use so we try to find out
let's say you want to buy the furniture
obviously you don't go to a online
grocery store because you need furniture
because there are
several websites so that is the first
decision you need to take
which website i should use so
once we have multiple websites you kind
of discard all the websites which don't
sell
furniture and you stick to those
websites which
sell furniture now within that we try to
find out
what is the ratings of this websites if
the ratings
is more that means they are reliable
the quality probably is good and so on
and so forth so only then you want to
buy from that particular website
so anything that doesn't satisfy this
credit area you close
all those websites close in the sense
you close the browser right so you still
are left with maybe a few of these which
satisfy your criteria that is which sell
webpages or websites that sell furniture
they have a rating of 4 and above and
then you look for
discount is somebody providing discount
greater than 20
then again you filter out some of them
which probably are not providing any
discount
and zero down to one or two websites
which are probably providing those
discounts and go ahead and select the
furniture and purchase it so this is a
very basic example
we probably don't follow this always
exactly the same way but just to
illustrate drive home the point
so we can answer a lot of questions
using data science for example when we
take a cap when we book a cab now to go
from
location a to location b what is the
best route
that the cab can take to reach in the
fastest way
or in the least amount of time there
could be several factors
there could be traffic there could be
bad road there could be weather
now all these come as inputs and
a decision needs to be taken as to which
is the best route
another example is tv shows so
netflix and maybe even other
a lot of other tv channels they have to
perform this analysis to find out
what kind of shows people are viewing
what kind of shows people are liking
and and so on and so forth so that
they can then sell this information to
advertisers because their main source of
revenue is advertising
so this is again major function of data
science
predictive maintenance we need to find
out will my car break down will my
refrigerator
break down in the next year or two years
should i be prepared to buy a new
refrigerator
you can potentially apply data science
here as well
and then in politics a lot of data
science
is applied in politics you must have
seen on tv
about u.s elections or in uk
or even in india nowadays everybody
is applying data science in elections
and trying to capture the votes or
rather the waters
influence the waters personalize
messages
providing personalized messages and so
on and so forth
and that is one not only that people
use data science to even predict who is
going to win the elections
it's a different matter that probably
not all predictions
come out to be true but then yes this is
they use data science to do this
predictions
so what is the process or what are the
various steps
in data science the first step is
asking the right question and exploring
the data basically you want to
know what exactly is the problem you're
trying to solve so that is
asking the right question so that is the
this
circle out here then the next
step is after exploring the data so as a
first step you will ask some questions
what exactly is the problem you're
trying to solve
and then obviously you will have some
data for that as input and you perform
some exploratory analysis on the data
for example you need to clean the data
to make sure everything is fine and so
on and so forth
all that is a part of exploratory
analysis
and then you need to do the modeling
let's say if you have to perform
machine learning you need to decide
which algorithm to use
and which model to use and then you
need to train the model and so on and so
forth so that's all
part of the modeling process and then
you run your
data through this model and then through
this process
and then you come out with the final
results of this exercise
which includes visualizing the results
and preparing
a way to communicate the results to
the concerned people so it could be in
the form of
powerpoint slides or it could be in the
form of a
dashboard which is basically what we
call
as a visualization and so all the
insights that have been gathered through
this exercise that has to be
communicated
in a proper way in an easy to understand
way which is again a key part
of this whole exercise communicating the
results
so what are the prerequisites for data
science
there are three essential traits
required for
to be a data scientist one is curiosity
you need to be able to ask
questions the first step in data science
is asking question what is the problem
you are trying to solve if you ask the
right question
only then you'll get the right answer
very often this is a very crucial step
where a lot of data science projects
fail because you're you may be asking
the wrong question
and then obviously when you get the
answer that's not the answer you're
looking for so it is very important that
you ask the right question needless to
say then the second part or the second
trait is common sense
so you need to be creative you need to
come up with ways to
use the data that you have and try to
solve the business problem on hand in
many cases you may not have all the data
that you need
in many cases the data may be incomplete
so that is where you need to come up
with ways what are the best ways to
fill these gaps wherever this is missing
and that's where common sense comes into
play
last but not least after doing all this
analysis
if you are unable to communicate the
results in the right way
the whole exercise will fail so
communication
is a key trait for a data scientist
maybe
technically you may be a genius but then
if you are unable to communicate those
results
in a proper way once again that will not
help
so these are the three main traits
curiosity common sense
and communication skills in a way you
can say these are the three c's
okay so what are the other prerequisites
first one so machine learning machine
learning is the backbone of data science
data science involves quite a bit of
machine learning in addition to the
basic statistics
that we do so a data scientist needs to
have a good hang or need to be very good
at
data science the second part is modeling
so modeling is also a part of machine
learning in a way
but you need to be good at identifying
what are the algorithms that are more
suitable to solve a given problem
what models can we use and how do we
train these models and so on and so
forth so that is the second
component then statistics statistics is
like
the core foundation of data science so
you need to understand
statistics and you need to have a good
hang of statistics in order to be a good
data scientist
and this will also help in getting good
results
programming is to some extent required
at least some program or the other would
be required
as a part of executing the data science
project
the most common programming languages
are python
and r python specially is becoming a
very
popular programming language in data
science because of its ease of learning
because of the multiple libraries that
it supports
for performing data science and machine
learning and so on so
python is by far one of the most popular
languages in data science if any one of
you is wanting to learn a new language
that should be python and then of course
you need to
understand databases how databases work
and how to handle databases how to get
data out of databases
and so on so these are some of the key
components of data science now coming to
the tools and skills that are used in
data science these are some of the
skills
from a language perspective it is python
or r and from a skills perspective
in addition to some of the programming
languages it would help if you have
a good knowledge or good understanding
of statistics
and what are the tools that are used in
data analysis
sas is one of the most popular tools
it's been there for very long time
and that's the reason it is very popular
and
however this is compared to most of the
other tools it is a proprietary
software whereas python and r are mostly
open source the other tools are like
jupiter
jupiter notebooks you have r studio
these are more development environments
and development tools so jupyter
notebooks is a interactive development
environment
similarly rstudio is for performing or
writing our code
and performing analytics and
performing data analysis and machine
learning activities you can perform in
rstudio it has a very nice ui and
initially r was not so popular primarily
because it did not have
user interface and rstudio is a
relatively new edition
and after the advent of rstudio are
became
extremely popular and there are other
tools like matlab and of course some
people do with
excel as well as far as data warehousing
is concerned
some of the skills that are required are
etl
so in order to extract data
and transform load etl stands for
extract transform load
so you have data in the databases like
your erp system or a crm system
you need to extract that and then do
some transformations and then load it
into your warehouse
so that all the data from various
sources
looks uniform then you need some sql
skills which is basically
querying the data writing sql queries
hadoop is another
important skill especially if you are
handling large amounts of data
and also one of the specialities of
hadoop is it can
be used for handling unstructured data
as well so it can be used for
large amounts of structured and
unstructured data then spark is a
excellent computing engine for
performing
data analysis or machine learning in a
distributed mode so if you have
large amount of data the combination of
spark and hadoop can be
extremely powerful so you store your
data
in hadoop hdfs and use spark as your
computation engine
it works in a distributed mode similar
to hadoop
like a cluster so that those are
excellent skills for data warehousing
and
there are some standard tools that are
available like informatica
data stage talent and also aws redshift
if you
want to do some on the cloud i think aws
redshift is again a good tool
data visualization tools for data
visualization some of the skills that
would be required
are let's say r your r provides some
very good visualization capabilities
especially for for developing during
development
and then you have python libraries
matplotlib and so on which
provides very powerful visualization
capabilities
and that is from skills perspective
whereas
tools that can be used are tableau is a
very very
popular visualization tool again that's
a proprietary tool so it's a little
expensive maybe but
excellent capabilities from a
visualization perspective
then there are tools like cognos which
is an ibm product which provides very
good visualization capabilities as well
and then coming to the machine learning
part of it the skills required there are
python which is
more for programming part and then you
will
need some mathematical skills like
algebra
linear algebra especially and then
statistics and maybe a little bit of
calculus and so on
and the tools that are used for machine
learning
are spark mlib and apache
mahoud and on cloud if you want to do
something
you can use microsoft azure ml studio as
well
so these are by no means an exhaustive
list there are actually many many tools
and probably
a few more skills also maybe there but
this is this gives a quick
overview like a summarizing of
summarization of
the tools and skills now moving on to
the life of a data scientist what does a
data scientist
do during the course of his work so
let's see
so typically a data scientist is given a
problem
a business problem that he needs to
solve and in order to do that
if you remember from the previous slide
he basically asks the question as to
what is the problem that he needs to
solve so that is the first thing
he has got the problem then the next
thing is to gather the data that is
required to
solve this problem so he goes about
looking for data from
anywhere it could be the enterprise very
often the data is not provided
in the nice format that he would like to
have it or
we would like to have it so first step
is to get whatever data that is possible
what is known as raw data in whatever
format so it could be enterprise data it
could be
it is a probably a requirement to go and
get some public data in some cases so
all that raw data is collected and then
that is processed
and analyzed and in prepared
into a format in which it can be used
and then it is fed into the analytics
system be it a machine learning
algorithm
or a statistical model and we get the
output
and then he puts these output in
a proper format for presenting it to the
stakeholders and communicating
those insights or the results to the
stakeholders so this is a
very high level view of like a a day in
the life
of a data scientist so gathering data
raw data
performing some quick analysis on that
and
maybe processing or manipulating this
data to
bring it into a certain good format so
that it can be used for the analysis
feeding this into that analysis system
that has been designed
be it mathematical models machine
learning models
and then get the results the insights
and then present it in a nice way so
that the stakeholders can
understand how about machine learning
algorithms so let's see what are the
various machine learning algorithms that
would be required for a data scientist
so these are a few of the algorithms
again there's not an exhaustive list we
have
regression is one of the supervised
learning models or techniques so in case
of regression
you try to let's say come up with
a continuous number so the difference
between
regression and let's say a
classification
is that in case of classification those
are discrete values whereas here we are
talking about regression where you let's
say you are trying to predict the
temperature which is a continuous value
or the
share price which is a continuous value
so that is regression so you need to
know what is regression how to perform
regression
and we need to understand clustering so
clustering is
one of the unsupervised learning
techniques
in this case there is no label data that
is available
and you get some data and then you want
to put this into some
shape so that you can analyze it and you
try to make sense out of it let's say
you
have one example is you have a list of
cricketers and they have not been marked
as
bowlers and batsmen or all rounders or
whatever right so you just have
their names and maybe how many runs this
code how many wickets they have taken
and so on but there is no readily
available
information saying that okay this person
is a batsman this person is a bowler and
so on so i'm talking about cricket
hopefully most of you are familiar with
the game of cricket so
how do we find out so then we put this
into a clustering mechanism
and then the system will say that okay
these are the people
who are all who have all scored good
amount of runs
so they belong to one cluster these are
all the people who have taken
good amount of wickets so they belong to
one cluster and maybe here are some
people who have taken
good amount of wickets and they have
made good amount of runs so they may be
belonging to one group and then we take
a look at it and then we label them as
okay people who have all together
and those who have you know scored many
runs they are
we label them as batsmen people have
taken a lot of wickets
we label them as bowlers and people
who have taken good amount of wickets
and also made some good runs we
label them as all rounders but the
system will just say okay this is
cluster one cluster two cluster three
the names we give we human beings have
to give the names
now decision tree is used for what is
known as classification
primarily it can also be used for
regression but by and large it is used
for
classification and here again it's a
very
logical way in which the algorithm goes
about classifying
the various inputs one of the biggest
advantages of decision tree is that
it's very easy to understand and it's
very easy to explain
why a certain object has been classified
in a certain way
compared to maybe some of the other
mechanisms like say
support vector machines or logistic
regression and so on so that's the
advantage of dictionary but that is also
very popular algorithm
then we have support vector machines
primarily for classification purpose
and then we have naive bayes this is a
a statistical probability based
classification
method so these are a few algorithms
there are a few more
that are not listed here but there are
some more algorithms as well
and by the way there are more detailed
or there are detailed videos about each
of
these algorithms available you can check
in the playlist
so now let's talk about the life cycle
of a data science project okay the first
step
is the concept study in this step it
involves
understanding the business problem
asking questions
get a good understanding of the business
model meet up with
all the stakeholders understand what
kind of data is available
and all that is a part of the first step
so here are a few examples we want to
see
what are the various specifications and
then what is the
end goal what is the budget is there an
example of this kind of a problem
that has been maybe solved earlier so
all this
is a part of the concept study and
another example could be a very specific
one
to predict the price of a 1.35 carat
diamond and there may be
relevant information inputs that are
available
and we want to predict the price the
next step
in this process is data preparation
data gathering and data preparation also
known as
data munching or sometimes it is also
known as
data manipulation so what happens here
is the raw data that is available
may not be usable in its current format
for various reasons so that is why in
this step
a data scientist would explore the data
he will take a look at some sample data
maybe
there are millions of records pick a few
thousand records and see how the data is
looking are there any gaps
is the structure appropriate to be fed
into the system
are there some columns which are
probably
not adding value may not be required for
the analysis
very often these are like names of the
customers they will probably not add any
value or much value
from an analysis perspective the
structure of the data maybe the data is
coming from multiple data sources
and the structures may not be matching
what are the other problems
there may be gaps in the data so the
data all the
columns all the cells are not filled if
you're talking about structured data
there are several blank records or blank
columns
so if you use that data directly
you'll get errors or you will get
inaccurate results so how do you
either get rid of the data or how do you
fill this
gaps with something meaningful so all
that
is a part of data munching or
data manipulation so these are some
additional
sub topics within that so data
integration is one of them
if there are any conflicts in the data
there may be data may be redundant or
data resident redundancy is another
issue
there may be you have let's say data
coming from two different systems
and both of them have customer table for
example customer
information so when you merge them there
is a
duplication issue so how do we resolve
that so that is
one data transformation as i said there
will be situations where
data is coming from multiple sources and
then when we merge them together they
may not be
matching so we need to do some
transformations to make sure
everything is similar we may have to do
some
data reduction if the data size is too
big
you may have to come up with ways to
reduce it
meaningfully without losing information
then data cleaning so there will be
the wrong values or null values or there
are missing values so how do you handle
all of that
a few examples of very specific stuff so
there are missing values how do you
handle missing values
or null values here in this particular
slide we are seeing three types of
issues one is missing value
then you have null value you see the
difference between the two right so in
the missing value there is nothing
blank null value it says null now the
system cannot
handle if there are null values
similarly there is improper data so it's
supposed to be numeric value but there
is a
string or a non-numeric value so how do
we clean
and prepare the data so that our system
can work flawlessly
so there are multiple ways and there is
no
one common way of doing this it can vary
from
project to project it can vary from what
exactly is the problem we're trying to
solve
it can vary from data scientist to data
scientist organization to organization
so these are like some
standard practices people come up with
and and of course
there will be a lot of trial and error
somebody would have tried out something
and it worked and will continue to use
that mechanism
so that's how we need to take care of
data cleaning now
what are the various ways of doing you
know if values are missing
how do you take care of that now if the
data is too large
and only a few records have some missing
values
then it is okay to just get rid of those
entire
rows for example so if you have a
million records and out of which
100 records don't have full data so
there are some missing values in about
100 cards so it's absolutely fine
because
it's a small percentage of the data so
you can get rid of the entire records
which are missing values
but that's not a very common situation
very often you will have
multiple or at least you know large
number of data set
for example out of million records you
may have 50 000 records which are
like having missing values now that's a
significant amount
you cannot get rid of all those records
your analysis will
be inaccurate so how do you handle such
situations so there are again multiple
ways of doing it one is
you can probably if a particular values
are missing in a particular column
you can probably take the mean value for
that particular column
and fill all the missing values with the
mean value so that
first of all you don't get errors
because of missing values and second
you don't get results that are way off
because these values are
completely different from what is there
so that is one way then
a few other could be either taking the
median value or
depending on what kind of data we are
talking about so something meaningful
we will have put in there if we are
doing some
machine learning activity then obviously
as a part of data preparation
you need to split the data into training
and test data set the reason being
if you try to test with a data set which
the system has already seen
as a part of training then it will tend
to give
reasonably accurate results because it
has already seen that data
and that is not a good measure of the
accuracy of the
system so typically you take the entire
data set the input data set and split it
into
two parts and again the ratio can vary
from person to person individual
preferences some people like to split it
into
50 50 some people like it as 63.33 and
33.3 is basically two third and one
third
and some people do it as 80 20 80 for
training and 24 testing so you split the
data
perform the training with the 80 percent
and then use the remaining 20 for
testing all right
so that is one more data preparation
activity
that needs to be done before you start
analyzing or applying the
data or putting the data through the
model then the next step is
model planning now these models can be
statistical models
this could be machine learning model so
you need to decide
what kind of models you're going to use
again it depends on what is the problem
you're trying to solve if it is a
regression problem you need to think of
a regression algorithm and come up with
a regression
model so it could be linear regression
or if you're talking about
classification
then you need to pick up an appropriate
classification algorithm
like logistic regression or decision
tree or svm
and then you need to train that
particular
model so that is the model building or
model planning process
and the cleaned up data has to be fed
into the model
and apart from cleaning you may also
have to in order to determine what kind
of model you will
use you have to perform some exploratory
data analysis
to understand the relationship between
the various variables and
see if the data is appropriate and so on
right so that is the
additional preparatory step that needs
to be done so
a little bit of details about
exploratory data analysis so what
exactly is exploratory data analysis is
basically to
as the name suggests you're just
exploring you just receive the data and
you're trying to explore
and find out what are the data types and
what is the is the data clean in in each
of the columns what is the maximum
minimum value so for example
there are out of the box functionality
available in
tools like r so if you just ask for a
summary of the table it will tell you
for each column it will give some
details as to what is the mean value
what is the maximum value and so on and
so forth
so this exercise or this exploratory
analysis is to get an
understanding of your data and then you
can take steps to
during this process you find there are a
lot of missing values you need to take
steps to
fix those you will also get an idea
about what kind of model
to be used and so on and so forth what
are the various techniques used for
exploratory data analysis
typically these would be visualization
techniques like you use histograms uh
you can use
box plots you can use scatter plots so
these are very quick ways of identifying
the patterns or a few of the trends of
the data and so on
and then once your data is ready you
decided on the model what kind of model
what kind of algorithm you're going to
use
if you're trying to do machine learning
you need to
pass your 80 percent the training data
or rather you use that training data to
train your model
and the training process itself is
iterative so
the training process you may have to
perform multiple times and once the
training
is done and you feel it is giving good
accuracy
then you move on to test so you
take the remaining 20 of the data
remember we split the data into training
and test
so the test data is now used to
check the accuracy or how well our model
is performing
and if there are further issues let's
say and model is still
during testing and the accuracy is not
good then you may want to retrain your
model
or use a different model so this whole
thing again can be iterative but if the
test process
is passed or if the model passes the
test then it can go into
production and it will be deployed all
right so
what are the various tools that we use
for model planning r is an excellent
tool
in a lot of ways whether you're doing
regular statistical analysis
or machine learning or any of these
activities are in
along with our studio provides a very
powerful
environment to do data analysis
including visualization it has a very
good
integrated visualization of plot
mechanism which can be used for doing
exploratory data analysis and then
later on to do analysis detailed
analysis and machine learning and so on
and so forth then of course you can
write python
programs python offers a rich library
for performing data analysis
and machine learning and so on matlab is
a very popular
tool as well especially during education
so this is a very easy to
learn tool so matlab is another uh tool
that can be used and then last but not
least
sas sas is again very powerful
it is a proprietary tool and it has all
the
components that are required to perform
very good statistical
analysis or perform data science so
those are
the various tools that would be required
for or that
that can be used for model building and
so the next step
is model building so we have done the
planning part
we said okay what is algorithm we are
going to use what kind of model we are
going to use
now we need to actually train this model
or build the model rather
so that it can then be deployed so what
are the various
uh ways or what are the various types of
model building activities
so it could be let's say in this
particular example that we have taken
you want to find out the price
of 1.35 carat diamond so
this is let's say a linear regression
problem you have data for various carets
of diamond
and you use that information you pass it
through
a linear regression model or you create
a linear regression model
which can then predict your price for
1.35 carat so this is one example
of model building and then a little bit
details of how
linear regression works so linear
regression is basically coming up with a
relation between
an independent variable and a dependent
variable so it is pretty much like
coming up with equation of a straight
line which is the best fit for the given
data
so like for example here y is equal to
mx plus c
so y is the dependent variable and x is
the independent variable
we need to determine the values of m and
c for our given data so that
is what the training process
of this model does at the end of the
training process
you have a certain value of m and c and
that is used for predicting the values
of any new data that comes all right so
the way it works is we use the training
and the test data set
to train the model and then validate
whether the model is working fine or not
using
test data and if it is working
fine then it is taken to the next level
which is put in production
if not the model has to be retrained if
the accuracy is not good enough
then the model is retrained maybe with
more data or you come up with a newer
model
or algorithm and then repeat that
process so it is an iterative process
once the training is completed training
and test
then this model is deployed and we can
use this particular model
to determine what is the price of 1.35
carat diamond remember that was our
problem statement so now that we have
the best fit
for this given data we have the price of
1.35
carat diamond which is 10 000. so this
is
one example of how this whole process
works
now how do we build the model there are
multiple ways
you can use python for example and use
libraries like pandas or numpy
to build the model and implement it this
will be
available as a separate tutorial a
separate video in this
playlist so stay tuned for that moving
on once we have the results the next
step
is to communicate this results to the
appropriate stakeholders so which is
basically
taking this results and preparing like a
presentation or a dashboard and
communicating these results to the
concerned people so
finishing or getting the results of the
analysis is not the last step
but you need to as a data scientist take
this results
and present it to the team that has
given you this
problem in the first place and explain
your findings explain the findings
of this exercise and recommend maybe
what steps they need to take in order to
overcome this problem or solve this
problem so that is the pretty much once
that is accepted and
the last step is to operationalize so if
everything is fine your data scientists
presentations are
accepted then they put it into practice
and thereby they will be able to improve
or
solve the problem that they stated in
step one
okay so quick summary of the life cycle
you have
a concept study which is basically
understanding the problem
asking the right questions and trying to
see if there is
enough data to solve this problem and
then even maybe gather the data then
data preparation
the raw data needs to be manipulated you
need to do data munching
so that you have a data in a certain
proper format
to be used by the model or our analytics
system and then you need to do the model
planning what kind of a model what
algorithm you will use for a given
problem
and then the model building so the exact
execution of that model
it happens in step four and you
implement and execute
that model and uh put the data through
the analysis in this step
and then you get the results these
results are then
communicated packaged and presented and
communicated to the stakeholders
and once that is accepted that is
operationalized so that is the final
step
now in the end let's take a quick look
at the demand for
data scientists data science is an area
of great demand
the demand for data scientists is
currently
huge and the supply is very low so there
is a huge
gap so what are some of the industries
with high demand for data scientists i
think
gaming is definitely one area where
it's a industry which is consumer facing
industry and a lot of people
play games and growing industry and it
requires a lot of data science
so that is an area where data scientists
are in demand then we have health care
for example data science is used for
diagnosis and several other activities
within
healthcare predicting for example a
disease
so health care is definitely finance
definitely
banks insurance companies all of these
there is a huge demand for data
scientists
marketing is like a horizontal
functionality across all industries
there's a demand for data scientists
there then of course in technology area
so
pretty much all of these areas there is
a lot of demand
globally there is a huge demand so this
is a very very
critical skill that would be required
currently
as well as in the future so let's
summarize
what we have seen so far we talked about
the need for data science what data
science can do
and what is data science and what are
the prerequisites
of data science in terms of the skills
and
programming languages and tools and so
on and so forth
we also talked about the various tools
that are available like python and r
and we did a comparison also between
business intelligence and data science
and we did a detailed discussion about
the life cycle of a data science project
with an example
and last but not least we talked about
the demand
for data scientists the global demand
there's a huge demand for data
scientists we talked about that
as well so with that we come to the end
of this
session thank you very much for watching
this video
and if there are any feedback any
comments please
or any questions please put it below and
we will get back to you provide your
contact information or email so that we
can respond to you
and thank you very much once again and
have a good day
bye
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here